Brasil se blinda ante el riesgo de que
se repitan los disturbios del domingo
pasado en los grupos de bolsonaristas
están convocando manifestaciones para la
retomada del poder en Brasilia y en las
principales ciudades de Brasil como Río
de Janeiro en la playa de Copacabana el
juez de la Corte Suprema Alexandre
dimoráis ha prohibido tajantemente que
los manifestantes corten carretera y
envadan edificios públicos las penas van
desde la cárcel hasta multas de 100.000
reales es decir 20 mil dólares
recordamos que desde el pasado domingo
hay una intervención Federal en el
Distrito Federal que es donde se
encuentra Brasilia el responsable de la
seguridad de este territorio capeli ha
dicho que es imposible que se repita las
mismas escenas de hecho en ese momento
la plaza de los tres poderes está
cerrada y no se puede acceder además la
mano dura de la ley está cayendo sobre
los supuestos responsables de permitir
los actos de vandalismo del 8 de enero
el gobernador del Distrito Federal
ibanéis Rosa fue alejado del Poder y hoy
la Corte Suprema ha decidido que tiene
que quedarse lejos del poder o sea
exonerado además el responsable de
seguridad del Distrito Federal Anderson
Torres va a ser arrestado hay una orden
de busca y captura recordamos que Torre
será el exministro de justicia de Jair
bolsonaro se fue asumió el cargo el uno
de enero
echó a los principales responsables del
dispositivo de seguridad de Lula se
marchó a Orlando a la misma ciudad donde
está ahora bolsonaro y anoche dijo que
volvería antes del tiempo para
entregarse a la justicia hoy no ha
podido de momento porque hay un caos en
el tráfico aéreo de los Estados Unidos
pero se espera que cualquier momento se
produzca su regreso y su detención